Suicide Squad comes out on August fifth
and some new faces are showing up that
we haven't seen on a big screen let's
dig a little deeper into who these
anti-heroes really are and what they
bring to the table I'm known to be quite
vexing I'm just forewarning you first on
our list is Enchantress who begins as
June moon and artist who stumbles across
a magical being in an old secret chamber
the rendezvous who leaves her with the
ability to transform into enchantress a
powerful sorceress who can heal and
teleport among other things next is
Harley Quinn she started as Harleen
Quinzel an arkham asylum psychiatrist
who fell in love with one of her
subjects the Joker in her faithfulness
to him shiri fashions herself as Harley
Quinn his devoted accomplice and
girlfriend she's exceptionally strong
and agile and in some cases immune to
toxins El Diablo is a third and most
recent shadow Santana he's a gangster
with pyrokinetic powers he seems to have
somewhat of a conscience because in his
past he burned down a building while
collecting a debt and turned himself in
after realizing innocent women and
children died Deadshot aka Floyd Lawton
is a cold-blooded assassin who is an
exceptionally talented marksman his
abilities are further enhanced by
cybernetic implants however like his
frequent adversary Batman he has no
superpowers of his own besides his
killer skills and mercenary attitude
Rick Flagg this military man is often
one of the leaders of the Suicide Squad
though he seems kind of conflicted about
it while highly skilled and trained flag
does not have superpowers he does
occasionally have issues with mental
instability which helps when you're on a
team with the name suicide in it Captain
Boomerang employs a lot of trick
boomerangs hence the name he's difficult
to work with and the others don't like
him very much Killer Croc is a villain
most commonly associated with Batman his
reptilian scales function as armor and
he has several special abilities
including regenerative powers and
superhuman strength endurance speed and
senses it'll be interesting to see what
he wears on his feet
kitana a Japanese woman who trains as a
samurai after her husband and children
are killed by the Yakuza she wields a
sword named soul taker which captures
the spirits of the people it kills
allowing her to communicate with them
Slipknot also known as Christopher Weiss
is really really good at ropes tying
them strangling people with them
developing formulas for unbreakable
versions of them etc etc this is a pre
eclectic group of characters gathered
together let us know which one is your
favorite in the comments below